in color theory the selection of colors
used in the design is called a color
scheme and knowledge is color schemes
use the main color plus one or more
adjacent colors while complementary
schemes use any two colors directly
opposite on the color wheel hi girls
I'm Tracey mounts guest host of contra
points the internet show where we talk
about sadness fascism sexual deviation
cult this week we'll be talking about
colors colors what the [ __ ] are they in
one beaker I have white and the other
brown pour them together and well I
don't know what the kids are calling it
it's delicious now according to some
so-called experts color is really
different wavelengths of electromagnetic
radiation but what about the shadow
illusion same wavelengths different
colors some people say I'm a man dressed
as a lady but I'm actually a lady who
used to be a man dressed as a man
dressed as a lady explained that
Professor Butler illusion what matters
more the way things are or the way
things look let's watch an instructional
video to learn more
[Music]
hi I'm Jackie Jackson host of the
Freedom report it's too early for this
today my guests are
[Music]
well who are you people
I'm dr. Abigail [ __ ] bein associate
professor of women's studies and author
of many many books most recently my
doctoral thesis sacred passage the
divine feminine influx and flow oh yes
and well you look familiar who are you
okay
well today my guests will be debating
the topic well here's a good one should
it be illegal to use the wrong pronouns
for transgender what do you think
Annabelle well Jackie liberation from
the oppressive institution of gender
begins with freedom of speech for
instance this cat person over here is
clearly a biological male in some sort
of costume wig now I of course the court
has right to trust however he wishes but
the fact remains that pronouns refer as
they always have referred to chromosomal
sex but perhaps you disagree sir that's
a human rights violation I'll smash your
[ __ ] face here we have a clear
illustration
transgender ideology is merely a
smokescreen for male violence against
women and my dude this is being taught
in our schools has been forced on her
children security and I have this caste
seminars law being silenced and
something must be done about the
encroaching trans agenda taking away
women's rights
all over Katie Queens but Abigail clocks
a car genders just likes color
some people say yellow some people see
blue it's all a matter of opinion or is
it let's hear the real team tapi sweetie
baby princess I feel ridiculous in this
dress yeah well you look ridiculous
because you wouldn't take the goddamn
cat ears off I think I'm gonna take the
dress off well don't do that I'm trying
to help you out girl if you don't want
to get misgendered it helps to thumb it
up a little I'm gonna take it off
but they'll leave you can change in
front of me I'm not a prude I'm gonna go
behind the curtain hmm I like looking at
naked people
why do you always hit on me I thought
you were into man well I swing both ways
I like boy dick and girl dick that's not
how that works I hate that the heart
wants what it wants
why did you invite me over here anyway I
saw what happened to you on the freedom
report and girl girl you cannot be a
trans woman on TV threatening people
with a bat you think it's morally wrong
to stand up to your oppressors no
morally wrong what does that have you
mean it was much worse than morally
wrong it was aesthetically wrong
it was unfeminine little you ever say to
me it's bad optics it's bad aesthetics
well it's reality matter at all to you
because the reality is I am a woman and
maybe a bunch of ignorant people don't
think I look like one but the way things
look isn't all that matters tabby this
is politics have you ever had a
conversation with the average voter
reality plays no role in politics
politics is aesthetics
politics is a
aesthetics that's literally what fascism
is have you even read benjamine fascism
is the introduction of aesthetics into
political life the military parades the
pageantry and communism responds by
politicizing art this is what I can't
stand about communists you want to turn
art into propaganda well art is already
ideology ah look instead of ruining art
why don't we fight the pageantry of
fascism with pageantry of our own and
you know who's gonna make that happen
oh well funded transwomen you stop that
what I'm just trying to monetize a
connected engagement community by
strategically leveraging my content
creator promotional media brand
analytics is that so wrong
you're so bougie I'm not the one quoting
German philosophers from memory
revolutionary philosophers whatever you
need to tell yourself look the point I'm
trying to make is that the world we live
in is not a philosophical world think
about Instagram it's all about
transforming your life into an envier
bull spectacle
if you cry yourself to sleep every night
who cares no one sees that they only see
the show you're putting on okay but life
is not a show politics is a show look
around you tabby try to understand
what's happening to the world the
President of the United States is a
reality TV star the 21st century is an
aesthetic century in history there are
ages of reason and there are ages of
spectacle and it's important to know
what you're in our America our internet
is not ancient Athens its Rome and your
problem is you think you're in the forum
when you're really in the circus I
thought you were just criticizing me for
being violent no you're against a reason
- I'm not against a reason reason is a
very powerful aesthetic if you're a man
and what if you're a woman oh don't be a
woman that's not a good idea how do you
remember that debate between Blair white
and that youtuber with the pink wig what
was her name I don't know she was
relevant back in 2017 anyway this was
before she transitioned and in that
debate
Blair looked like she had two X
chromosomes and the other one looked
like this awkward Dulli in an anime wig
not long in the camera I vaguely
remember I think I read an angry blog
post about it well the pink wig lost
that debate so bad it was embarrassing
to watch not really I mean
she was right and her arguments were
better ah tabby sweetie honey
angel darling princess baby arguments
don't matter how pretty you are matters
is this really where you're going with
this tabby if you want to be a public
figure so to her later you're gonna need
to take the trans girl black pill oh boy
if you're a trans woman in the public
eye
what matters is one thing and one thing
only and it's always been the thing that
matters why the realness
verisimilitude you have to look like a
[ __ ] woman
there it is there it is is right we
don't say it in public but we all know
it and we all feel it what does it even
mean to look like a woman oh don't give
me that PC [ __ ] I'm trying to have a
real conversation here we all know what
it means I don't know what it means
women have a lot of different looks
they're bold women bearded women
muscular women wide shouldered women and
what is society's opinion about those
bald bearded wide shouldered women is
this just about you making me wear the
dress again the dress is the last of my
concerns I mean where do I even start
with this you're wearing combat boots
you cannot be wearing combat boots why
not a lot of cysts women wear them since
women well they're hopeless aren't they
fully clickable so you want me to look
like a woman without imitating sits
women yes do not under any circumstances
imitate this women they have no idea
what they're doing well where does your
idea of womanhood even come from then
does a Vika viably huh the archetype of
the eternal feminine and where does that
come from
poets teenage gay boys on Instagram the
only people with any coherent vision of
contemporary womanhood that's insanity
is it tabby look at my face look at this
highlight
does that look like the product of
insanity to you I mean yeah kind of who
puts on that much makeup to drink tea at
home good banter well done but trans
women have to overdo it you need to be
so good at makeup that every sis women
you know comes to you for advice you
need to toss your hair and cross your
legs you need to smile even at people
who hate you eliminate every aggressive
impulse
you must be a blossom floating along the
surface of a stream your hands are not
tools their ornaments at the ends of
your arms so you literally are what
turfs think trans women are literally a
man's idea of a woman well men have the
power men make the rules and it's
ultimately men who are the judges of
womanhood so you can't really blame me
for having to deal with that situation I
can blame you for dealing with it by
demanding we all conform to a bunch of
ridiculous stereotypes not stereotypes
performances you look philosophy so much
having you read Judith Butler gender is
performance we're all born naked and the
rest is literally drag womanhood is not
what you are it's what you do and trans
women have to be virtuosos of womaning
so according to you there's no
difference between a trans woman in a
drag queen no you're misinterpreting
what I'm saying I don't mean performance
in the sense of pretending to be
something you're not
I mean performance in the sense of
everything you do the way you style
yourself your posture the way you speak
an authentic performance is just a
habitual performance and nothing more
than that
so trans women just starting their
transition are pretending to be women I
mean isn't that kind of what it felt
like you transition the same way you get
anywhere in life you fake it till you
make it so according to you a trans
woman it's just a full-time drag queen
that's what any woman is what about
gender nonconforming assists women
they're not doing womanhood in that way
well yeah that's why those women are
marginalized they're going off the grid
of what society recognizes as a
womanhood you don't want to end up like
that do you and hold on are you saying
that of a sis man dresses like a woman
talks like a woman takes female hormones
is gendered female but other people and
spends his whole life pretending to be a
trans woman that is literally as much of
a woman as we are yeah that's absurd but
it's absurd because the example is
absurd no sis man would do that it's
like asking is a straight man gay if he
only sleeps with men like yeah pretty
much see this is a philosophy at its
worst pointless speculative fiction and
it's a distraction from what we're
really talking about which is you
getting rid of those combat boots I
thought we were talking about philosophy
no we're talking about shoes why don't
to justify what I wear to you you're
apparently fine wearing designer dresses
around your communist friends
the left will abide a regal queer look
your performance theory doesn't explain
why trans people exists in the first
place if gender is just a bunch of
learned behaviors then why did we reject
our male upbringing and decide to live
as women what matters is that we
identify as women we can express that
identity in different ways but it's the
identity not the performance that makes
us women but you can't be a woman
without performing womanhood
without action and without social
recognition the identity is meaningless
if womanhood is nothing to you but a
private daydream then you may as well do
what those [ __ ] say and identify as
a helicopter because unless you're
living womanhood the identity is
literally that meaningless that's very
unfair to pre-transition trans people
well this isn't a tumblr cuddle party
girl I'm trying to talk about what's
really true I didn't say it was
insensitive I said it was unfair
identifying as a woman before you
transition is a psychological reality
that implies a potential to live your
inner truth no one has ever sincerely
identified as a helicopter it's just a
troll example true but even if they were
sincere there would still be no reality
to it because helicopter is not an
actual social role whereas you can
become a teacher a doctor or a woman but
you have to work to get there and
ultimately society has to let you what
do you mean I can identify as a doctor
and go around handing out diagnoses but
if no one recognizes me as a doctor then
I'm not really practicing medicine am I
but that analogy means that our
womanhood can be revoked at any moment
all it takes is being misgendered it's
scary but isn't that the situation we're
in why did you get so angry when the
turf called you sir isn't it because in
that situation she robbed you of your
womanhood that's ridiculous I am a woman
that's my reality it doesn't depend on
other people's opinions I know you're a
woman I'm just saying that in that one
moment you effectively hide your gender
canceled another way of looking at it is
gender is aesthetic not rational
either you're perceived as a woman or
you aren't there's no reasoning your way
into it oh don't worry about that
I don't argue I'm a woman I smashed I
know you do and it's a bad look
is this about the shoes again yep here
put these on
absolutely not I'm not wearing those yes
you are [ __ ] no you put this on and
I'll scratch you behind the ears later
okay fine
now walk that was the worst thing I've
ever seen
well you're the one who made me do it
look don't stop around like that keep
your shoulders back and steady all the
movement comes from your hips and you
want to put the weight on the balls of
your feet here I'll show you
[Music]
your turn
do it right the category is cat girls
[Music]
yes [ __ ] that was flawless
it was iconic I'm living for this I'm
loving this for you you're doing so good
for yourself I'm never doing that again
ah why not because it's not who I am all
your advice is just trying to turn me
into you
well that's not what aesthetics is
aesthetics is the expression of an inner
truth it'll only ever be a second-rate
Justine but I can be a first-rate tabby
well kids this week we learned a
valuable lesson about the importance of
being yourself shut up look I know I'm
not cool okay I know I'm not pretty and
I know you think you're too good for me
because you mostly pass and I know you
and your friends laugh at me behind my
back
people stare at me because I'm a
transgender furry and that's weird but
I'm a [ __ ] queer icon because I'm not
like you because I'm not like anyone but
myself and because I'm willing to stand
up to the people who oppress us and I'm
willing to stand up for the girls with
beard shadow and deep voices the girls
even other trans women make fun of and
when in the history of the world has
anyone but me ever stood up for them
that's why everyone knows who toby is it
was the last time anyone talked about
Justine
while tabby I didn't know you had that
in you but so what
so male to anime Twitter stands you big
deal you're mad aren't you
I'll get over in a few weeks look you're
right you have to be yourself
trying to be someone else is always a
bad look so I guess if combat boots are
your aesthetic then wear them well and
make it work but sometimes being
yourself is not enough sometimes you
have to become yourself and for you I
think that means that the Smashing has
got to stop
I mean with the Nazis it's one thing but
you cannot be menacing radical feminists
with a bat I wouldn't have to smash if
literally anyone else we're willing to
stick up for us your delicate notion of
femininity is a product of the privilege
you share with a lot of thin white sis
feminists wow it must be so hard for you
out on the streets as a fat woman of
color shut up
I'm just saying don't claim a struggle
that isn't yours girl you could have
what I have you just have to work for it
instead of killing this heart on the
tragic victim you are raised a white boy
you've got to go to college and learn
all that philosophy yeah it's hard being
a trans woman of any background but you
still stand on a lot of privilege I look
at all the photos of trans women who are
murdered in this country and they don't
look like you or me why don't you use
your privilege and use your education to
actually do some good in the world
instead of this elective revolutionary
LARPing you make me sound like the
self-indulgent one I'm sorry I'm not
hardworking enough to go to brunch dates
and cocktail parties with trans phones
I've seen Minds change and hearts soften
before my eyes you don't win friends and
allies with a bat they're just using you
well who do you think benefits and who
do you think it's hurt when you go out
into the world and represent transport
is masculine and violent who do you
think benefits when they trot you out to
be feminine and meek and acquiescence I
guess we can't win can we you want to
just chill out and watch youtube videos
yeah okay forget about the disrespect
facts don't care about your feelings it
turns out that every chromosome every
cell in Caitlyn Jenner's body is male
with the exception of some of his sperm
cells you don't know what you're talking
about
you're not educated on genetics
you cut that out now or you'll go home
in the ambulance yeah that seems mildly
inappropriate for a political discussion
so look at that and I feel like on my
end it's like I'm always I feel like I'm
always a damage controlling for the
trans community which is so frustrating
you'll go home in an ambulance
damage control it so frustrated you'll
go home and so frustrated you'll go home
it's imperative that we actually use
terms that refer to something if you
want to talk about gender as distinct
from sex and then talk about you're a
very feminine biological man you know a
new paddle surgeries to prove it
happened then I think that we can talk
about what is the appropriate pronoun to
use my problem is the the tabie I don't
want to fight with you we're surviving
in this [ __ ] world to go there and
you'll always be my sister well I'm glad
I love you
white long I was in love once I was in a
smoky Roadhouse oh it said Cincinnati
bent over a pool table the year was 1985
and to this day and the perfume of cheap
whiskey hits my nostrils at just the
right moment I can almost feel the beer
stained billiard cloth against my cheek
oh let's watch it all on VHS cassette to
learn more
[Music]